wow Dove and Aaron all right luminous
you're like bursting through the screen
you're luminous
oh my goodness thank you so much that
means a lot coming
thank you
uh y'all congrats on season two thank
you thanks
it's amazing uh I gotta start off with
Dove because can we just talk about
Jenny and how like incredible she's like
a little mysterious but like fun and
flirty and like I don't know she's just
all the things yeah did you have to
watch you know any like what was the
research to go into this character of
Jenny I guess is what I'm asking well I
feel like um the the Liza portrayal of
Sally Bowles was something that was very
much in my brain in the recesses of my
brain and I feel like growing up in the
theater you're always doing impressions
you're always like trying to take your
best stab at the most iconic characters
so I I had a good idea of what I wanted
to do
um but again you know nothing is ever
going to be Liza like that role is so
important
um not only like historically but also
emotionally for for so much of the
community also myself
um so I think I I got I I wanted to
focus on getting her isms and getting
her mannerisms and things that people
would instantly recognize and then let
the actual character of Jenny that was
written which is you know different
sort of shine through those isms and and
take on her own thing right because I
think in Jenny's mind she wants to be
the ultimate like manic pixie dream girl
where there's like no real you know
substance going on because if there's
substance then there's reality and then
she has to face her pain so she has all
this like projection stuff that she
thinks is very sparkly and wonderful and
cool that is actually pretty off-putting
a lot of the time which I think is you
know there's a lot of that in the Sally
bowls character that I could draw from
amazing oh I love the depth to that I
love getting into your mind about that
it's incredible it makes me kind of see
Jenny in like this this other light as
well so thank you for that
um Aaron your look is the best this
season see
was it to dress up in this era and are
you gonna grow out your hair it was so
fun to do that
um I the first time I put the wig on I I
was just like I was in the hair makeup
trailer and it just makes you carry
yourself different makes you kind of act
different
um and then the clothes I kind of was in
this like basically dressed like Robert
Plant with this amazing wig so it just
you know I it's so far removed from what
you know we kind of see in our present
day or how I dress and so it just really
it makes you walk different talk
different feel different and it just
does does so much work for you as an
actor that you then just get to and you
know it's a visual medium right so
people are responding to what you look
like so I don't have to like put that on
top of it so that's already working for
me so it just makes my job so much
easier
I love it I love it well you carried it
very well very well
all right Dove kaput
one word cut puts
um
can we talk about the chairography in
this I'm going to call it choreography
yeah like there were so many chairs you
were working it tell me about the prep
and like the mentality of going into
this this dance number yeah well um I
I'm again I've said this like 100 times
but I'm I'm very open about not being a
dancer
um and being better at you know maybe
floor work very like precisely placed
floor work
um I was really nervous going into this
and um I knew there was it was going I
was going to be barely clothed and I
knew there was going to be some
flexibility happening and I knew I was
going to be doing a lot of core work and
balancing the one thing I will say that
I think surprises me when I watch it
back is those chairs look nailed to the
ground and they are like three pound
chairs and you are always like this
close to breaking your neck doing it
like for me the thing that that was
hardest that didn't probably look very
hard was when you have one foot on the
base of the chair and then you're like
tracing it with the other foot where
like one foot is up and you're like tick
tick tick like that scared out of me
that was very very scary not easy
killed it I'm telling you when I watched
that I was like it was not easy and
that's why I was asking like what was
the prep the ab work like all of that I
could tell those chairs were light
thank you amazing amazing word well
thank you so much it was wonderful to
meet y'all and I'm excited for everyone
to get introduced to schmicago thank you
thank you have a beautiful day Loomis
you too thank you